here's a way to do will do this 10 time
I think we can do the first one first
you know I often like to take them out
of water will do the first one first who
gets more you've got this amounted to
anything shared among this many people
versus Batman a dream [ __ ] oh yes very
okay so how do we work this out number
one who agrees I think I didn't put up
that these people he reckons hm couple
heads up yeah okay Thank You hands down
someone who reckons they agree can you
tell us how you convinced yourself and
how you could convince us that those
people get more Kimmy you divide 2.5 57
and see what like each person gets
behind that and then you do that with
them okay fantastic so when you see this
language of sharing right um Kim is
exactly right sharing and dividing their
these very parallel ideas right if you
want to share something you've got to
divide it into slices so then you can
get each of these okay what do you get
what are you get for example today one
divine two and a half by seven and have
an answer for that Nicola is stretching
or you actually okay oh I see you're
talking about bills by rights are you
two thousand five hundred divided by
seven is that correct now interested
okay so a couple features happen there
which is great cuz they don't remember
something we don't earlier which is
conversion right so we could do some
mills or in liters by the way there's
something I really like about doing this
in mills drum leaders yeah it's a bigger
number right so yeah exactly i'd have to
worry so much about these decimal point
I mean I will but I don't they're not as
much of a concern what was your original
/ again too
is that this one or that one which
number 357 remainder 1 okay i guess if
we were using the same kind of method
you have to do not four but 4,000 / 11
and you're a toss what you got for that
as well okay so it's pretty close but
yes the 11 people despite me a big group
they're sharing a big enough amount of
age get more a little bit okay all right
now here i need your help i need to have
your help a little bit did you member
yes there we all would do this question
and struggle with a little bit right
part of what makes a heart is its phrase
that's written in a bit of an unusual
way they're fractions whereas if we try
them with decimals everyone could do
this really easily so I'll actually get
your calculators out can you guys work
out for me um what is to fears as a
decimal in fact you might not even need
your calculator for battle to fit as a
decimal 0.4 0.4 okay the 307 that's a
bit trickier but I calculator can do to
take care of that as well I can someone
tell you about 3 over 7 years as a
decimal so say cuz I'm tell me what it
actually is okay good be good thank you
ok so now now I need some help I've got
one two three four five answers and I
need to know which ones actually fit and
which ones not so let's have a look at
each of them can I get you five from
general EDS Charlie can you test this
one find out what it is a decimal okay
can you fall right Daniel to a tin can
you do like a I think you can do that
one pretty quickly this one I think I
should all be able to read off ah let's
see Frank
shrimati bet okay can you do this one
and if finally over here on the right
uppercut about to earn you do the live
okay please tell you what these are as
decimal okay okay all right what we got
six okay very good you guys had me 0.5
we can all do this one when we got here
is 0.1 way you're doing the last one
about 2 years 29 / 70 John do so we got
it you guys got it yeah I got your point
401 yeah and last one okay all right
very good okay oh I know this wall i do
then what's right that looks totally
saved it okay good ok so now now did you
order future calculators and pens on
your hands and full attention now that
we've got everyone's down on the board
okay so now we're ready to have a
discussion about right one of these is
loving that Matt's is it can tell you
like am I in the right ballpark or not
you know I'm see this range here this
pair of numbers they could be anything
is anyone seen in a few recently they
discovered a new
they don't know where they discovered it
oh yeah yeahs discovered a galaxy just
thought it's not that far away
everybody's hey recently I recently
discovered this planet orbiting around
this started this does a really big deal
it's really special because it's the
very very closest star to the Sun right
that means that after the Sun it's our
closest star if we wanted to go on like
you know colonized somewhere and make a
new thing in another star system if our
startling what is up or something this
is where we'd go okay now what's really
cool is we know that the planet is kind
of like that like in terms of size and
what's made of and how we know comes
down to numbers like these right like
how what's the mass of this thing how
far is it from its star what's its
atmosphere made up or it's going to be
made up of numbers like this like how
much oxygen is there how much nitrogen
so getting this number within a range
could be a really important question for
us how many of our answers are in the
right range how many look carefully how
did you see I see to write this one's
good did you put for one it's pretty
close to the mill and so is this one in
fact this one who did that work no
wonder so is that the average between
the two is that me yeah yes I can take
it looks like it's exactly halfway do
you see that look football 428 it's yeah
okay which is probably how you went to
that okay so working out questions like
this is really interesting because you
come up with a whole bunch of answers
there's an infinite number of answers
that are right um but it's not that easy
to find them okay